I've been covering the Donald Trump
Russia relationship or possible
friendship for a long time now and many
people in our audience have resisted it
and over the weekend we have learned so
much about it and we will talk about
that remember last week when Donald
Trump attempted to one-up his earlier
comment suggesting that his supporters
could assassinate Hillary Clinton by
making the assertion that President
Obama founded Isis I'll remind you about
that clip from last week just so we can
all get on the same page take a look to
say Isis is honoring President Obama
right he is the founder of Isis he's the
founder of Isis is the founder yeah he
founded Isis and I would say the
co-founder would be crooked Hillary
Clinton so repeating it doesn't make it
true and as it turns out Michael McFaul
who's a former US ambassador to Russia
and professor at Stanford University
noticed something interesting about
Trump's Obama founded Isis thing from
last week check out the tweet that
former US ambassador Michael McFaul sent
sent saying by the way Trump's line that
Obama founded Isis echoes exactly a myth
propagated by Russian state-controlled
media and bloggers and we've talked to
you extensively about these Russian
bloggers and how they spread pro-kremlin
and we also have evidence of pro Trump
propaganda all over the internet and
we've been exploring the connections
between Trump and Russia for a long time
and Trump of course continues to deny
them now let's it let's look at what we
knew prior to this weekend and what we
know now based on a new york times
article that came out last night if
you're trying to distance yourself from
pro-kremlin pro Putin Russian factions
first of all it might be good not to
parrot their conspiracy theories on the
campaign trail that's number one we have
now learned though that Paul Manafort
Donald Trump's campaign manager who
replaced the fired Corey Lewandowski he
tied to pro-russian politicians in
Ukraine there's a new report from the
New York Times and it exposes some
handwritten Ledger's which show that
12.7 million dollars in undisclosed cash
payments were designated for Paul
Manafort from uh mr. Viktor Yanukovich's
pro-russian political party from 2007 to
2012 this is according to Ukraine's
newly formed National anti-corruption
bureau and in addition to that Louis we
have now learned that criminal
prosecutors are investigating offshore
shell companies that helped up Viktor
Yanukovich's inner circle finance their
lifestyles and Trump's own campaign
manager Paul Manafort is now being
investigated as of CNN's statement this
morning for possibly receiving illegal
payments in Russia if you're trying to
distance yourself from Russia Louis
maybe parroting pro-russian talking
points and hiring a guy who reportedly
received millions and off the record
payments from pro-russian groups is not
the best way to distance yourself it
yeah another example of how Trump seems
to know one who is competent or or
trustworthy or fantastic or great or or
terrific wants to work for Trump and the
rhetoric when it comes to the rhetoric I
I I could easily see the the the similar
rhetoric just being a coincidence right
the Obama rhetoric that type of thing
short uh that wouldn't that would
surprise me but now we're getting a
little deeper and it's uh it's kind of
ugly and not only that it the rhetoric
matching up might be not a big deal if
that was all we had but we also know
that trumps views on the Ukraine Russia
conflict actually changed after hiring
Paul mana for Donald Trump first seem to
support Ukraine's territorial integrity
back in September he spoke by video feed
to a gathering of of political and
business elites in Kiev and he said that
that his rhetoric was very very pro pro
Ukrainian and then all of a sudden Paul
Manafort gets involved and now Trump's
rhetoric on Russia is softening he in
winces the Republican National
Convention II although he says he didn't
even really know what was going on which
actually further lends itself to this
connection to to pro Russia which is
that metaphor did this on its own under
the guise of being part of or
representative of the Trump campaign
russia may genuinely see all of this is
hilarious right we've talked louis about
how russia may just think hey we should
try to get Trump elected because he'll
be such an embarrassment that in
contrast russia will actually look like
a more legitimate player in the world
politics game uh well that might be it
maybe not just looking like a more
legitimate player but perhaps Putin
wants someone in office that he thinks
is weak and that he could easily
manipulate sure and so uh there could be
very serious consequences not good if
you're trying to show there is no
connection between you and your campaign
and Russia Trump is doing the exact
opposite of what he should be doing